of my working-class background and I'm
now a high rate taxpayer Labor's
messages often leave me feeling
demonized and ashamed of earning a good
salary how can I vote for you when you
make me feel like this well I'm going to
try and change let me see if I can
change your mind look look I think that
the thing that's happening in Britain at
the moment is it's the very richest in
our society I'm talking about like the
top 1% people earning over 150,000
pounds a year who are doing sort of ok
and I think lots and lots of people
including on middle income are finding
life all really tough now the question
is how we do something about it and I
hope you'll get a different message for
me tonight if that's the message you've
been getting for me let me give you an
example tuition fees some people have
criticized me for wanting to lower the
burden of tuition fees from nine
thousand to six thousand pounds they say
it'll help middle-class families well
too right I want to help middle-class
families because I think lots of
families are saying if my son or
daughter is leaving university with 44
thousand pounds of debt that isn't a
good situation let's do something about
it with fair changes so I look I want a
country where you feel you're not
struggling you can get on and that's one
of the changes we'd make if you're a
socialist does that mean that you're
anti wealth creation no I think wealth
creation it says on my party card
Democratic Socialist I think that wealth
creation is an incredibly important part
of building a more prosperous society
and a fairer society but the difference
with me Kay and this is important for
the audience is I think the way we
succeed is not simply with those at the
top doing well but all working people
succeeding look I say is when working
people succeed that Britain succeeds now
that might sound like a political slogan
it isn't it's actually a reality over
the way a country gets on so if hard
works rewarded for everyone not just the
bankers with six-figure bonuses if you
get a regular and seven-figure bonus or
seven-figure bonuses if you get regular
hours you know and you've got some
security if you're going out to work and
doing the right thing for the country if
you're having an NHS that you can rely
on that's better for the whole country I
think we all benefit from that